- And action, Adam.
- Aloha.
It's the original beach boy
himself,
me, Adam DeVine.
Last year, I took my house party
to New Orleans,
where I took over a bar,
but this year--
no, no, no, no, no.
I'm taking over a resort
in freaking Hawaii.
- Um, excuse me?
[snaps fingers]
What's going on here?
- I'm introducing my show,
"House Party," right now.
- No.
- We are currently doing the--
- I am here to tell you
that you are currently
not doing that.
- We are, though.
- No, you are not,
because guess what?
You're not supposed
to start filming your show
until tomorrow.
Okay?
This space is reserved
for a wedding today,
so you will have to wait.
I'm so sorry.
- I'm getting married
during the show.
It's a comedy show/my wedding.
- So--so you're the groom
in the Kahananui wedding?
- Yep.
So, this is my wedding.
Okay?
Anyways.
Like I was saying, last year I--
[sound cuts out]
- She unplugged the sound, dude.
- Hey, Adam.
I'll be watching you,
and I can unplug your show
at any time.
- Jesus Christ.
Can you--plug it back in.
Just...
- "House Party" Hawaii, baby!
[theme music plays]
♪ ♪